[Music]  [Music]  who are you  in this vast multiverse  stephen strange  your reckoning is long overdue  [Music]  only beaters may 6th tickets on sale now  i've been  dreaming  every night  every morning  the same  nightmare  stranger  [Music]  the freight of the multiverse  depends on us  careful stephen  this path exacts a heavy toll  [Music]  okay  marvel studios knocked her straight to  the multiverse of madness only beaters  may 6 tickets on sale now  if you're watching doctor strange on a  screen this small  you're in the wrong universe  experience the multiverse of madness  the way it was truly meant to be seen  big prove it  [Music]  it's more powerful when it's cinematic  and there's no place more cinematic  then cinemark doctor strange in the  multiverse of madness get tickets now  see it in cinemark xd  you